The Joe Rogan experience.
I had this other experience, I just wanted to share about, um,
this was a DMT experience where I realized that, you know,
we all have the capacity for evil, if we aren't careful in a sense.
So the DMT kind of dissolved my ego VE quickly.
It was the first time I ever did.
DMT was sitting in a circle with a group of people at LAN.
This was Terrence McKenna. And, um, you did DMT with Terrence McKenna. Yeah.
Yeah. And Ralph Metzner from, and we would, um,
there was about eight of us and we would, each of us, it takes about 15 minutes,
10, 15 minutes. So we,
one person would do it would then would sort of close eyes,
lie down and come back after 15 minutes or so,
and then tell the story about what happened.
And then we passed the pipe to the next person,
and this was like a whole evening of mm-hmm <affirmative> DMT stories.
So my DMT experience was this, um, I saw this, um,
horizontal line. Then I saw vertical line. Then I saw color. It turned red.
Then it turned into cubes like squares. And then it turned,
turned into like an MCs painting that was just,
and then I was gone and it was just, it didn't make sense. Then I was gone.
And then I just had this insight that in the deepest recesses of who I think I
am in this inner voice, that's kind of always talking to you.
That's that I was using English and I didn't invent English.
I it's all the product of all these people that came before me.
So even in my most inner private self I'm intermixed with everybody else and
everything that came before me. Oh,
and I had this beautiful experience of going back to the big bang and all of
this kind of sweep of evolutionary history and I'm part of everything.
And everything's part of me and it was all this beautiful stuff.
And then I realized this sort of logical part of my mind was like, well,
if everything's of you and you're part of everything,
then Hitler is part of you too. Ooh, it's inner. And,
and that was very shattering for me.
Cause that was in the DMT experience that was in the DMT.
Did you see Hitler in the experience I did and I,
I got million golden Hitler floating around you. Well, that, that,
that we all have that capacity, that,
that if we wanna claim that we're connected with everything that it's,
it's not just the evil out there that it's potentially in, in me.
And it was very shattering. And the next day, um,
we did ketamine. And so this is where I did more sea Hitler.
So this is actually an experience that has, um,
helped me with my political strategy in a way of maps is doing is both
drug development and drug policy reform. So under this experience, the next,
it was very depressing and shattering to realize that I couldn't just say all
the evils out there that I have this capacity that Hitler's inside me.
So the next day under ketamine, um,
I was hovering above and behind Hitler. He's giving one of these speeches,
like the Nurnberg rally kind of things.
And the ketamine gave me a bit of remove. So I didn't freak out. I wasn't,
I was there, but I was not there. So I didn't feel vulnerable in that way.
And I saw him doing this speech and I'm thinking, how do I get into his head?
How do I help him not wanna murder and kill? And you know,
what can we do to, you know, undo this evil? And then I saw this, um,
the, he Hitler salute near the end of his speech and he would go, you know,
he put up his hand like that and then everybody in the crowd would do it back to
him.
And I felt like it was the one pushing out this energy and then the many pushing
it back to him and giving him and they would go back and forth and the intensity
was kind of increasing.
And at that point I was just realizing there's no way to get into his head that,
that he's, it has to be voluntary and that he was getting so much for,
from it that he wouldn't.
And I felt this panic rising above me. And I felt that if I were to panic,
I would never be able to be effective in the world that I would just have turn
away from that. And then with ketamine, you can still breathe.
And so I realized that if I just breathe,
that might help me deal with this fear.
And I started deep breathing and then came this idea that
ironically, rather than trying to change the mind of the one,
we need to change the mind of the many and that they don't get as much out of it
as Hitler did that. They're giving away their power to him.
And so that's where we need mass mental health. So you hear a lot of people. I,
I had a chance to talk to Steve jobs for an hour wow. Long time ago. And, um,
but he was like, um, stuck in the sixties in a way. He was like, God,
if we could just give all these politicians L S D. And I was like, yeah,
that might be good, but they might resist it.
But really we have to base this new compassion and spirituality in the masses
and millions, tens of millions of people.
This, this Hitler thing. Can I ask you, like, when I've never done ketamine,
so when you're having this experience, what is, what is it like,
do you realize that you are in a psychedelic experience that you're in some sort
of a hallucination,
or does it actually feel like you are there? Like, what.
Is it felt like I was there, but I had this sense that I was somehow a,
are there also not there and removed.
But you knew that you were tripping well at the time.
Do you think? I, I lost that for a while. And as the panic kind of built up,
I had this thought I can breathe. So I,
I did have that sense that I was on a drug and that if I were just to modulate
my breathing and, and that would help relax me.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> <affirmative>. So I, I had that thought,
but I felt like I was really there and it was way, you know,
I've seen movies of world war II,
and I've seen movies of Hitler giving speeches,
but I was never as emotionally connected to it.
And in the moment as I was during this ketamine experience. Hmm.
So it was kind of a dual situation where I was there,
but a part of me felt removed and safe and this thought
like, okay, just breathe. Um, but I,
but I never had that insight before about the high Hitler salute and how this
energy exchange between and how the rallies were very dramatic.
And that's where he cemented his power through these.
Rallies. Well, you know, Hitler was on all kinds of drugs. Yes. Yeah. Um,
there was God, I keep forgetting who told us that story, Jamie,
but there was a story about Hitler convincing Moline.
Do you remember? I've tried.
I've tried to look it up and find it. I.
Can't, I can't find it either. I,
it might not have even had happen on a podcast.
That's the problem is I have so many conversations and my memory's just so
full. It's just, there's no room. I got like folder stuffed all over the place.
I don't know where anything is,
but the story was that Hitler was in the middle of
campaigning and he was completely,
and he was supposed to meet Moline and he was gonna not meet Moline cuz he was
so exhausted.
But then they shot him up with testosterone and liquid cocaine mm-hmm
<affirmative>. And when they did that,
he was just bouncing off the walls and he cornered Moline and talked to him
for five hours and convinced him not to leave the effort to leave
the war effort. And he sort of, one of the, the,
the things that this, uh,
story was basically pointing to was that much of Hitler's mania
and much of this, uh,
rabid attack that he had put on the rest of the Western world
was fueled by amphetamines. Yes.
And cocaine and testosterone.
And that they just kept injecting him with all this that gave him this insane
confidence and insane maniacal aggression.
And it completely makes sense if you think about what he did.
And then we also know that Kika were on amphetamines and
many of the Nazi soldiers were on amphetamines. Well, the.
Blitz Greg, how they would do that, this kind,
they were days and days on amphetamines. Yeah.
And then that promotes aggression as well.
And just psychotic delusions. Yeah.
And he had this delusion of creating this master race, which is,
and that's the most cocaine idea of all time, right?
Like this SOIC where I'm gonna engineer the greatest human race ever.
And you know, and, and,
and to be able to look at that idea from this cocaine
fueled or amphetamine fueled perspective to the point where you're willing to
commit genocide in order to accomplish your goal.
Yeah. Drugs were a big factor in the third. Yeah. Very much so. Um,
also we know that John Kennedy was given amphetamines. That's.
Miss Dr. Feelgood, right? Yeah.
Dr. Feelgood was a legitimate doctor that would run around and give people,
amphetamines found. What'd you find there buddy? The story. Oh, who,
where is this from? Uh, history.
Hit.com. Did Hitler's drug problem changed the course of history?
He got a shot of this stuff called.
EAL. Okay. Hitler took EAL for the first time before the dreaded meeting,
his mood changed immediately.
Everyone was very happy that the fewer was back in the game.
His enthusiasm was such that on the way to the airport to fly to his meeting
with Sini, he demanded a second shot.
The first shot had been administered subcutaneously,
but the second was intravenous. It was even better.
During the meeting with Sini,
Hitler was so energized that he pretty much just shouted for three hours.
There's several reports from that meeting, including an American,
an intelligence report to the embarrassment of everyone in attendance, Hitler,
didn't stop talking throughout the entire duration of the meeting Moline.
He couldn't get a word in edgeways,
meaning he wasn't able to voice his concerns about the war effort and perhaps
raise the prospect of Italy leaving.
So Italy stayed at the end of the day.
Hitler told morale the of today is totally yours. Wow.
So more must have been the doctor. Yes.
You could do find out what that is. <laugh> okay. EUCA do similar to heroin.
In fact, it's stronger than heroin.
It also has an effect that heroin doesn't have. It makes you euphoric,
but I think they 'em up with some other stuff too.
The word was that it was I'd read har I'd read cocaine
and oxycodone. So I just hit Google and that's what comes up. Oh wow.
Interesting. But I had heard, um, cocaine.
It says there five milligrams of cocaine too. Where's it there though?
Under a DX Wikipedia there. Yeah. Oh, is that what's in there.
It's meth and Coke mixed together. Oh, so that's what EIL is. Okay.
That makes sense. So EIL is five milligrams of cocaine and three milligrams of
methamphetamine. Wow.
So D D I X it's a,
a methamphetamine based experimental performance enhancer out by Nazi Germany.
Wow. So that's the stuff. Catch new episodes.
The Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify. You can,
can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can download
episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.